vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir l'as cannes
au cameroun ce soir ce sont les matchs
du groupe d l'egypte a battu le soudan 1
0 et le nigeria s'est imposé 2 0 face à
la guinée-bissau et prend la première
place de son groupe au-delà des
résultats rester avec nous pour avoir
les détails des matches notamment avec
benoît paire au shekel suivi egypte au
soudan en particulier
au soudan justement c'est le deuxième
jour de désobéissance civile qui
paralyse khartoum des émissaires
américains à la rencontre de la société
civile depuis le 25 octobre dernier ils
sont nombreux à se mobiliser dans le
pays et demande un retour à la
transition démocratique et que le
pouvoir soit rendue aux civils
explications dans cette édition
des vaccins antique vide africain
l'afrique du sud lance la première usine
du continent qui fabriquera ses propres
dose de a à z les premiers vaccins sont
attendus dès cette année
et on commence par la can ont rejoint
notre envoyé spécial benoît perreault
cher en direct depuis yaoundé qui a
suivi pour nous l'egypte qui est s'est
imposé face au soudan benoît comment
s'est passée la rencontre est-ce que la
victoire finalement des phares en était
telle logique
oui plutôt logique l'egypte qui remporte
donc une deuxième victoire de suite et
qui assure l'essentiel cette
qualification pour les huitièmes de
finale mais ce n'est pas ce match face
au soudan qui va pouvoir leur servir de
référence tant les soudanais n'ont
absolument rien montré au cours de la
rencontre à part c'est vrai un coup
franc dangereux en fin de match pourtant
le soudan pouvait encore espérer se
qualifier en cas de victoire ce soir ils
se sont pourtant contenté de défendre ça
n'a pas suffi puisque les pharaons
l'entente porter un but du défenseur
mohamed abdel monem à la 35e pour
débloquer la situation ça n'a pas
forcément débloquer les attaquants
égyptiens qui ont continué d'avoir la
possession sans se montrer réellement
dangereux beaucoup d'imprécisions dans
les passes et puis des centres qui ont
été tirées pour personne la star mohamed
salah qui était évidemment très très
attendu ce soir ici il a été assez
inoffensifs sur son côté droit et
pourtant contrairement aux matches
précédents ces partenaires ont réussi à
le trouver il a eu plus de ballons à
négocier
malgré cela une seule occasion
dangereuse pour l'attaquant de liverpool
un petit numéro dans la surface
soudanaise ce soir qui a réveillé le
stade amadou ahidjo belle affluence ici
d'ailleurs ce soir il était aux
alentours de 25 mille la plupart venus
pour assister au show ça là ils ont pris
beaucoup de photos on voyait les flashs
lumineux à chaque fois qu'il
s'approchait du poteau de corner mais le
score final donc 1 0 il n'a pas
forcément brillé sur la pelouse ce soir
mohamed salah l'egypte qualifié à la
deuxième place de ce groupe derrière le
nigeria qui a signé une troisième
victoire de suite face à la guinée
bissao une victoire 2 à 0 pour les super
eagles seule équipe a signé trois
victoires consécutives dans cette phase
de groupe ils ont fait le plein de
points c'est nigérian confirmant leur
statut de favorites j'y affrontera le
deuxième du groupe e en huitièmes de
finale le nigeria qui va lui devoir
encore attendre pour connaître son
prochain adversaire en huitième ce sera
sans doute le malawi confirmation demain
soir
merci benoît merci beaucoup benoît
perché pour toutes ces explications
hier ce sont les marocains qui ont
terminé premiers du groupe de leur
groupe c avec un match très remarquée
selon les commentateurs match nul 2
partout face au gabon qui est aussi
qualifié et fait une bonne première
phase d'entâmes écouter ce supporters
des panthères très confiant pour la
suite de la compétition au micro disent
pas l eau bien usés
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ces
jeunes et son onze national nous offre
du beau jeu l'idéal pour le gabon serait
à cette coupe d'afrique au cameroun d'au
moins finir avec le plafond de verre est
ce que on peut s'attendre d'en arriver à
la finale on va laisser le temps
répondre et on va prendre chaque match
progressivement nous sommes très heureux
de constater que l'équipe d'un sauna
s'en sort très bien elle est
complètement regroupés au sein d'un
certain nombre d'anciens dont le
capitaine bruno ecuélé manga et nous
pouvons nous réjouir que c'est une
équipe nationale où il n'y a plus de
notion de stars aux manceaux voulait
tirer mon chapeau à bruges et caudéran
là et comme le voyais jouer vous année
c'est quelqu'un qui est venu pour faire
une performance quelles que soient les
conditions il ya un jeu collectif qui
s'est développée qui est extrêmement
intéressant il ya des possibilités
on connaît l'équipe en face on sait déjà
qu'ils ont rencontrés en huitièmes de
finale donc je crois à notre niveau nous
sommes complètement prêts
et le gabon affrontera le burkina faso
ce dimanche 23 janvier à l'hymne b
alors si les stades étaient pleins lors
du premier match d'ouverture où les
lions indomptables ont joué face au
burkina faso c'est sûr mais depuis
l'intérêt serait un peu retombé en cause
les protocoles sanitaires mis en place
qui serait contraignant et le prix des
tickets dissuasif pour certains face à
ce manque d'affluence gouvernement
camerounais multiplie les initiatives
reportage à yaoundé de richard en alena
et stéphanois
trois quarts des sièges vides et une
enseigne de près de 40000 places qui
sonne creux ce soir là lors de cette
rencontre entre les comores et le maroc
au stade omnisports de yaoundé depuis le
début de la can seuls les matchs des
lions indomptables attire les foules de
quoi gâcher quelque peu la première
phase de la compétition
mais pour ceux supporters qui a puisé
dans ses économies pour assister à
plusieurs matches impossible de rater
l'événement majeur le foot j'aime ce
qu'elle considère comme pour moi ce qui
nous motive ce que j'ai toujours eu les
canards et lapins de chez moi le monde
apprenait la tan je crois franchement à
vivre un prix minimum de ticket d'entrée
3000 francs cfa soit près de 5 euros
dans un pays où environ 40% de la
population vit avec moins de 2 euros par
jour ajoutez à cela un pass vaccinale
est un test pcr négatif pour avoir accès
au stade des normes exigées par la caf
et en décourager une majorité des
camerounais comme l'expliquent cet
entraîneur de football rencontré dans un
quartier populaire de la capitale la
première barrière c'est le vaccin il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont réticents
n'est ce pas qui veulent pas entendre
parler du vaccin si on ajoute à cela
encore les distances n'est ce pas au
niveau des stades vous voyez bien que
c'est pas évident il faut débourser
beaucoup d'argent pour aller au stade à
plus de mille kilomètres au nord dans la
ville de garoua
une ambiance survoltée dans cette fan
zone contrastant avec des stades clair
c'est mais des centaines de supporters
venus assister au match de la sélection
camerounaise dans ces lieux plébiscité
depuis le début du tournoi
de kerckhove il n'est pas exigé celui
d'avoir un masque et une température
normale pour accéder à la phase est
hélas bien c'est cool il ya de la joie
et les amis sortent pour que les stades
eux trouveront sur leur public le
gouvernement a réduit les heures de
cours et de travail pour les élèves et
les fonctionnaires dans les villes comme
yaoundé des navettes gratuites assure le
transport vers les enceintes ou des
places sont même offerte par les
employeurs et certains ministères
on passe au soudan où un deuxième jour
de désobéissance civile a paralysé
aujourd'hui khartoum suite aux violences
policières qui ont entraîné la mort d'au
moins sept personnes et fait des
dizaines de blessés lundi par ailleurs
des émissaires américains ont rencontré
des militants pro démocratie pour
discuter d'une sortie de crise le point
avec bastien renault pas de
manifestation cette journée de
mobilisation à khartoum mais bien de la
désobéissance civile alors qu'est ce que
cela signifie et bien que ceux qui
soutiennent le mouvement pro démocratie
doivent rester chez eux et ne doivent
pas aller travailler et il semble que ce
mouvement est plutôt suivi il ya eu de
nombreuses barricades érigées un petit
peu partout dans le khartoum au cours
des deux derniers jours leur but était
bien empêcher ceux qui veulent aller
travailler de se rendre au travail et
empêcher les forces de l'ordre de se
déplacer facilement dans khartoum je
vous propose d'écouter deux personnes
qui étaient derrière ces barricades des
interviews enregistrées par notre équipe
à khartoum
l'objectif de la désobéissance civile ça
peut faire chuter le conseil militaire
peut renverser blâme et les milices
janjawid qui contrôle le pays
et nous continuerons jusqu'à ce que nos
exigences soient respectés une
transition démocratique et un
gouvernement civil
on en a assez du parti du congrès ils
ont détruit le soudan durant trente ans
nous ne voulons plus de détails sur
militaire il nous faut un gouvernement
civil qui protège les droits des
citoyens soudanais qui répondent à leurs
besoins qui défend leurs décisions et
protègent leur liberté d'expression
difficile pour une majorité de sudan et
de se priver de revenus durant plus de
deux jours la situation économique dans
le pays est extrêmement complexe ils ne
peuvent pas se permettre de faire grève
durant trop longtemps l'objectif est
bien c'était d'avoir une action coup de
poing qui montre au général burhan qu'il
reste mobilisé et qu'ils seront toujours
dans la rue au cours des prochaines
manifestations des manifestations qui
seront organisées au cours des prochains
jours
malgré la hausse de la répression il ya
eu 71 morts au moins depuis le coup
d'état le 25 octobre dernier
en république démocratique du congo la
police annoncent avoir arrêté lé
meurtrier présumé de lucas attanasio
l'ambassadeur italien avait été tué le
22 février dernier à goma selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète le groupe
arrêtés auraient eu l'intention de
kidnapper le diplomate et de demander
une rançon il serait par ailleurs accusé
aussi d'avoir commis divers meurtres et
attaques crapuleuses
et nous vous en parlions en début de
semaine voici les images d'alpha condé
quittant la guinée pour se faire soigner
aux émirats arabes unis ce sont les
premières images du président déchu
publié par la junte au pouvoir depuis le
coup d'état du 5 septembre dernier
c'est le pays le plus touché par le cos
vis du continent et c'est lui qui
luttent pour une égalité d'accès au
vaccin l'afrique du sud lance au cap la
première usine de fabrication locale
premières doses sont attendus dès cette
année le point avec washington
c'est une étape majeure dans la lutte
contre le coguic 19
le président sud africain cyril
ramaphosa et l'homme d'affaires patrick
son chien on inaugurait ce mercredi une
nouvelle usine de vaccin au cap c'est la
première du continent à héberger tout le
processus de fabrication du début
jusqu'à la fin le milliardaire américain
né en afrique du sud me transférer une
partie de la technologie et des
matériaux utilisés au sein de sa firme
californienne aux scientifiques sud
africain transformant le pays en un
centre de référence pour les
technologies médicales
l'idée c'est d'intégrer cette
technologie grand provoque unième siècle
au processus de fabrication en afrique
du sud par les sud-africains pour les
sud-africains
et nous dépasserons
ce n'est un secret pour personne le taux
de vaccination en afrique est faible
seulement 10% de la population est
complètement vaccinés contre le coc vite
l'ouverture de cette usine devrait
permettre de renverser la tendance
l'afrique ne devrait plus être la
dernière à avoir accès au max 1 lors de
pandémies
nous nous débrouillerons seul nous
sommes déterminés
et cette usine en est la preuve l'été
est ce que
cette nouvelle usine devrait être
capable de produire 1 milliards de
vaccins par an d'ici 2025 mais elle ne
produira pas que des vaccins contre le
coc vide l'objectif est de fournir des
médicaments pour le continent tout
entier
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de khartoum à
brazzaville en passant par libreville
restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]